welcome to another thankful Thursday I
believe it's important for entrepreneurs
to take time every week to thank the
people in your life in your business of
having impact who helped you who believe
in you who want to see you rise up say
thank you to them and it'll make
everybody feel great so so today I want
to thank Jason Inge and Jason is a
instructor at Toronto dine salsa which
is a school that I'm involved in and I
went to his class last night learning
how to do West Coast Swing and I've
never done West Coast xx before was my
first time with my wife and we had a
blast and it was fun because I learned
salsa and became good at it became an
instructor became part of the school and
have been taking a dance class for a
while because I got up to a certain
level and it's fun going back to basics
and being a beginner again and I think
it's a great lesson for entrepreneurs if
you're feeling like you're you're in a
rut you don't have momentum you don't
have creativity go start over at
something become a beginner get that
beginner's mind going again learn
something new if it's a dance class if
it's an art class if it's how to use
video cameras learning Photoshop
whatever it is learn something new
because when you're learning and you're
challenging yourself you get that
creativity and that energy and it's
gonna flow to other areas of your
business on your life now I must admit
I'm not the greatest student just in
general I tend to want to go faster than
the instructor is is teaching and I
won't always listen and I want to do
things my way and usually get really
creative and come up with different ways
of doing something that may not be
totally legit so I'll be busting out
other moves that I think can fit in West
Coast Swing but totally aren't West
Coast Swing but but that's that's me as
a student I guess my wife is the exact
opposite where she is
dutifully listening doing everything
exactly as it's supposed to be and so is
it's a fun combination and a side bonus
is my parents are both in the class too
so that's a fun kind of family thing to
do together for one hour every week so
Jason thank you for your patience in
dealing with me and had a great time
last night and looking forward to next
week's class and for all of you watching
take time today to say thank you to
somebody who's had a positive impact on
your life from your business somehow
it'll make them feel great it'll make
you feel great
spreading that positive karma out in the
world so it comes back to you and I'll
help you and your business grow so say
thank you to somebody this week and
believe you guys liked this video you
want to see more subscribe to the
channel see more just like it thank you
so much for watching I'll see you soon
hi every Cal English here with mermaid
junkie TV are you on evans newsletter
subscription if not you should be I read
every single one and you should too
ciao
you